c'est un outil en cours de développement
au sein du groupe airway l'intelligence
artificielle et pour en parler nous
sommes avec Alexandre rente bonjour
[Musique]
alors comment est utilisé aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle dans vos
solutions alors en fait c'est assez
simple on avait tendance à se focaliser
sur le produit
sachant qu'aujourd'hui tous les produits
sont plus ou moins efficaces on a
souhaité il y a grigier cette
intelligence artificielle afin
d'optimiser la consommation électrique
du foyer concrètement qu'est-ce que ça
donne bon bah qu'est-ce que ça donne
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'on propose des
produits de climatisation de chauffage
ainsi que de la production d'électricité
via les panneaux solaires donc
l'objectif c'est de faire communiquer
tout cet environnement ensemble et de
pouvoir
en fonction en fait de la production
d'électricité des panneaux par exemple
actionner ou non certains systèmes
thermodynamiques afin d'optimiser la
consommation d'énergie et finalement ces
solutions participent à la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique tout à fait
l'objectif étant d'avoir un maximum
d'énergie renouvelable au sein de
l'Union européenne alors je disais
l'intelligence artificielle là vous êtes
en cours de développement mais vous
pensez déjà à l'étape d'après quelles
sont les réflexions en cours aujourd'hui
chez airwell de toute façon ce
développement va être sur du long terme
il va être en constante amélioration en
fait via différents algorithmes que nous
allons développer au fil des années donc
ce projet finalement n'a pas vraiment de
fin merci Alexandra NT avec plaisir je
rappelle que vous êtes chef produit au
sein du groupe airw